[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
بعد اشهر من المعارك زيلينسكي يلمح الى
امكانيه الانسحاب من باخموت ويقول ان
ارواح الجنود اولويه
خلال زيارته
يقطع الطريق على روسيا ويؤكد ضروره ابقاء
الحوار مفتوحا مع الصين
[تصفيق]
يطالب للجمهوريين في الكونغرس بالغاء
تمويل وزاره العدل والاف بي اي بعد
الاستماع للائحه اتهامه
مشاهدينا مباشره الى بروكسل ومؤتمر لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي في ختام اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه النيتو
هل ستنتظرون حتى توافق روسيا على منحه
الحق في الحصول على الزياره القنصليه
ثانيا حدث تبادل للسفره مؤخرا
معتقلين امريكي هل يمكن للروسيا ان تبادل
الصحفي مع اي
معتقل روسي
وبطبيعه الحال هناك سابقه الان فرضاها
خصومنا للحصول على تبادل السجن شكرا شكرا
جزيلا لك
بدايه سمعتيني اقول هذا الكلام من قبل من
منظوري الشخصي ومنظور وزاره الخارجيه ليس
هناك اي اهميه اكبر من امن الامريكيين في
العالم وهذا يشمل اولئك
الذين يتم اعتقالهم بطريقه ظالمه او
يختطفون ويمنعون من العوده الى وطنهم
والالتحاق باسرهم فيما يتعلق
نحن نعمل من خلال التركيز على الاعتقال
الظالم وهناك عمليه نتبعها
ولكن
بالتاكيد نحاول ان نسرع الخطى قدر
المستطاع وسترك هذه العمليه تاخذ مجراها
انا شخصيا لا شك بانه اعتقل بطريقه ظلمه
من قبل روسيا وهذا تحديدا ما قلته لوزير
الخارجيه عندما تحدثت اليه خلال هذا
الاسبوع واكدت انه يجب اطلاقه فورا
ولكن اريد ان اتاكد هذا ما فعلته دائما
انه هناك طبعا اجراءات رسميه نتبعها وهذا
ما سنفعله
واتوقع ان تنتهي هذه الاجراءات قريبا بشكل
اوسع عندما يتعلق الامر اولا
وكما قلت من قبل
هذا المقترح الموجود على الطاوله منذ شهور
وسددته لوزير الخارجي من روسيا عليها ان
تحرج التقدم بشان هذا المتاح المقترح
لسعاده بول الى ارض الوطن وفي كلتا
الحالتين
تمت
موازنه بين اعاده في المواطنين الى الوطن
وما يجب القيام به لتحقيق ذلك واعتقد وكما
اظهرنا ذلك في السابق ونتيجه كذلك
للتشريعات الموجوده لدينا اضافه الى ادوات
اخرى حتى عندما نبدو الج هود لسعاده
مواطنين عيادتهم الوطن نريد ان نزيد
الضغوط
والعقوبات على اولئك الذين يقومون بعمليه
اعتقال ظالم للمواطنين الامريكيين وهذا ما
قمنا به ونعمل ايضا على تنفيذ قانون روبرت
وغيره
اعطي الكلمه الان الى الممثل فريدوم
لدي سؤال السيده بالامس وزير خارجي
اوكرانيا قال بعد لقائه
مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا القدر من كلمه
بلينكن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه طبعا خلال
اجتماع الخارجيه ونكمل النشره الخامسه
ونركز فيها ايضا على الجانب الاوكراني
الذي كان بلينك ان يتحدث عنه ولكن في
الجانب الميداني حيث المحا الرئيس
الاوكراني
للمره الاولى المح الى امكانيه سحب القوات
الاوكرانيه من باخد موت قال في مؤتمر
الصحفي مع نظيره البولنديه اندريدودا ان
الوضع يزداد صعوبه في الخطوط الاماميه
بالمدينه حيث تدور معارك ضاريه مشيرا الى
ان الاولويه ستكون لحفظ ارواح الجنود
زيلنسكي اضاف انه سيتخذ القرار المناسب مع
ازدياد الموقف تعقيدا
من جانبه اعلن الرئيس البولندي استعداد
بلاده لتسليم كل مقاتلاتها من طراز ميكس
29 الى اوكرانيا مستقبلا اضاف خلال مؤتمر
صحفي مع زيلينسكي ان بولندا سترسل ست
مقاتلات من طراز ميك 29 قريبا ليرتفع
الاجمالي الى اربع عشره مقاتله
وفي متابعه متابعه لزياره الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون الى بكين قال الرئيس
الفرنسي انه ليس من مصلحه الصين استمرار
الحرب في اوكرانيا موضحا انه لم ياتي الى
الصين للتفاوض بشان السلام في اوكرانيا
لانبكين ستساعد في هذا الشان على حد وصفه
كما شدد ماكرون على انه في حال قيام الصين
بتسليح روسيا فانها ستصبح بذلك متواطئه في
خرق القانون الدولي
ولكن ما الذي يريده من خلال هذه الزياره
لبكين يبدو ان رئيس الفرنسي اراد قطع
الطريق على روسيا التي تتنامى علاقاتها مع
بكين وذلك منذ الحرب في اوكرانيا ماكرون
قال ان الحوار مع الصين ضروري ولا يمكن
ترك المساحه لروسيا ايضا الرئيس الفرنسي
يامل من خلال هذه الزياره في ثني نظيره
اوروبا انحيازا لروسيا او على الاقل يضمن
حياديه من قبل الصين في هذه الازمه بحسب
صحيفه الجارديان وعلى الرغم من ان الصين
تظهر دائما وكانها تسعى الى حل سلمي في
حرب اوكرانيا تقول باريس لم تصل الى حد
انتقاد الرئيس الروسي بوتين بل ستواصل
تزويده بالسلاح زياره ماكرون هي الاولى له
للصين منذ كورونا وسيتخللها اكثر من 6
ساعات ستجمعه بنظيره الصيني لاتاحه المجال
لمناقشه مواضيع عده على اجنده الدولتين
الى ج انب حرب اوكرانيا ستشمل الجلسات
قضايا رئيسيه منها تقويه العلاقات
التجاريه مع الصين فوفقا للجارديان يرافق
ماكرون 60 شخصيه من قطاع الاعمال على امل
التوقيع على اتفاقيات جديده ومربحه
ومع رغبه فرنسيه اوروبيه في توطيد
العلاقات الاقتصاديه مع الصين اين وصل حجم
التبادل التجاري بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
وروسيا بحسب الحرب في اوكرانيا دعونا
نتابع
ما حجم التبادل التجاري بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي وروسيا عام 2021 كانت روسيا
خامسه اكبر شريك تجاري للاتحاد الاوروبي
حجم التبادل التجاري بين روسيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي بلغ اكثر من 257 مليار يورو اي
نسبه 6% من اجمالي حجم التجاره في الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع العالم اما بعد الحرب في
اوكرانيا فتضاعف العجز التجاري بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي وروسيا باكثر من اربعه
اضعاف لكن قطاع الطاقه كان الاكثر تضررا
حيث تضاعف العجز في تجاره الطاقه ثلاث
مرات تقريبا الى
183 مليارا و600 مليون يورو في الربع
الاول من 2022
مقارنه بالفتره نفسها من 2021
المزيد معنا من النبيين
الصحفي المتخصص في الشؤون السياسيه
الدوليه اهلا بك سيدي هل لك ان تبدا
بقراءه للمشهد وللتصريحات حتى الان وما
الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه من هذه الزياره
شكرا على دعوتكم
اولا اعتقد عن بالنسبه لسين وفرنسا تعد
زياره مكرون لسين مهمه للخيا فهذه زياره
تمثل ومزيدا من تداول العلاقات الصينيه
والفرنسيه ومع تعزيز المستمر لشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين بلدين وكان ايضا
توسيع توسيعه التعاون بين بلدين في مجالات
الاقتصاد وتجاره وثقافه وتعاليم والعلوم
تكنولوجيه وستعمل هذه زياره على تعزيز
تبادلات وتعاون بين الصين وفرنسا في
مجالات السياسه
الثنائيه بين الجانبين ولكن نحن نعلم
التطورات الجيوسيه نعلم ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي بصوره مباشره او غير مباشره
مشارك من خلال المفاوضه
والتشاور مع الرئيس الصيني وايضا الفرنسي
وبالتالي موضوع اوكرانيا لا يمكن استبعاده
الا يعتبر الاولويه
[ضحك]
المتحده ما الدور الذي يمكن ان تلعب الان
الصين ما المطلوب منها اكثر من ذلك
في الواقع لن تكن دول الغروبيه
ابدا محايده في قضيه روسيا واوكرانيه فهي
تلوم روسيا وتدعم اوكرانيا ولذلك لن تكون
غلوب راضيه ابدا عن موقف الصين عن مبادره
الصين ما لم تكن مبادره الصين منخزه تجاه
اوكرانيا لكن في راي السبب جذري للازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه عن انتشاره ناتوا يهدد
امن دول اخرى وادى ذلك الى اجباري روسيا
على اتخاذ اجراءات العسكريه لذلك اكد
للسباكين في مبادرته على ضروره مصالح
الاساسيه والعامل القومي لاي دوله
المعنيه لاجلاعي المشاورات وحوار مبادرا
من الى سعر الاسلحه باستمرار الى ساحه
المعركه اعتقد ان زياره ماكرون لسين
ايجابيه بالنسبه لحل سلمي لهذه الازمه
ما يتبقى من هذه الزياره ثلاثه ايام ليست
بالقليل لن نتمنى ان نستمع للمزيد من بكين
تشاوشي جيون الصحفي المتخصص في الشؤون
السياسيه الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك
طبعا لم تكن باريس الوحيد التي تتخوف من
تنامي العلاقات بين موسكو وبكين الناتو
ايضا عبر عن ذلك امين عام
ان مساعده الصين لروسيا ستكون خطا تاريخيا
دعونا نتابع
مستقبل اوكرانيا يقع ضمن محيطها في اوروبا
والمحيط الاطلنطي وانضمام اوكرانيا للحلف
يتطلب ان تكون مستقله وغير معرضه للغزو
الروسي وهي ستصبح جزءا من الحلف يوما ما
اتفقنا على تطوير برنامج استراتيجي على
مدى سنوات للارتقاء باوكرانيا لمستوى
الحلف اود الاشاره الى ان مساعده الصين
لروسيا ستكون خطا تاريخيا
الشماليه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من
تداعيات مسؤول الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب امام محكمه منهات المساء امس
يبدو ان ترامب لا يتوقف عن الانتقادات
شديده اللهجه بحق الادعاء العام في
نيويورك ترامب الانتقادات للقاده اخوان
مارشن الذي مثل امامه في المحكمه متجاهلا
تحذيرات التي وجهت له بالتوقف عن اثاره
الراي العام طبعا في هذه الاثناء طلبت
الجمهوريين في الكونجرس الغاء تمويل وزاره
العدل ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي حتى
يعودوا بحسب تصريحه الى رشدهم ترامبال عبر
منصته للتواصل الاجتماعي تروس ان
الديمقراطيين استخدموا النظام القانوني
كسلاح ضده وان الشعب لا يسمح بذلك الرئيس
السابق اشار ايضا ان كل المحللين
القانونيين والسياسيين اكدوا له ان التهم
التي وصفها بالجائره بحقه لا ترقى الى
جريمه
في فرنسا يبدو ان الامور تتجه للتصعيد في
اعقاب فشل الحكومه في احتواء غضب النقابات
العماليه بسبب قانون التقاعد المثير للجدل
حيث اعلنت نقابات عماليه فشل الاجتماع
الاخير مع رئيسه الوزراء اليزابيث بورن
بعد ان رفضت سحب مشروع القانون دعونا
نتابعه
ندعو الشعب الفرنسيه للخروج بقوه للانضمام
الى المسيره العديده غدا في باريس وفي
جميع انحاء فرنسا ليقول للمره الحاديه
عشره لا لهذا الاصلاح غير العادل والوحشي
من الواضح ان الاجتماع فشل عندما لا تسمح
رئيسه الوزراء باي طريق الى النقاش
انضمت القاذفات الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
ذات قدرات نوويه ب 52 الى مناورات عسكريه
في كوريا الجنوبيه بحسب وزاره الدفاع
الكوريه الجنوبيه هذه القاذفات الامريكيه
بعيده المدى شاركت بجانب المقاتلات
الامريكيه من طراز اف 16 واف 35 وصل مخاوف
من اجراء بيونج يونج تجربه نوويه جديده
قالت وزاره الدفاع الكوريه الجنوبيه ان
مشاركه هذا الطراز من القاذفات سيحسن الرد
على الامريكي ضد اي استفزازات في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه من جانب
وفي مكه المكرمه اطلقت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
مجموعه من الدراسات الهندسيه والفنيه
للتاكد من جوده منظومه الخدمات المقدمه
للمعتمرين والزوار والتي منها انظمه
التكييف شبكات الاتصالات والشاشات
الالكترونيه بجانب طبعا الانظمه السمعيه
والبصريه على كل المزيد معنا من الحرم
المكي مراسل العربيه هاني نصفيان لينقل
لنا الاجواء من هناك هاني تفضل
نعم اهلا بك ميسون واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه العربيه مره اخرى طبعا الى جانب
الدراسات التي نفذتها رئاسه الشونه
الحرمين لقياس جوده الانظمه السمعيه
والبصريه وكذلك
اجهزه انظمه التكييف لدى المعتمرين
والزوار هناك ايضا اعمال وخدمات تطوعيه
تقوم بها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين عموما سوف
يتحدث معي ضيفي بشكل سريع وهو الاستاذ
عادل الجهني وهو وكيل المساعد للعمل
التطوعي مرحبا بك استاذ عادل نتكلم اليوم
بشكل سريع كم عدد الفرق التطوعيه لتتابع
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين وما دورهم حياك الله
اخوي هاني اليوم نتكلم عن 27 فريق تطوعي
بين فريق خدمات انسانيه وخدمات اجتماعيه
كذلك التايهين والخدمات الصحيه
طيب نشاهد اليوم عندنا عربات متحركه وهم
من هل هذه لها قيمه او مبلغ هذه خدمه
مجانيه تقدم لكبار السن والمحتاجين عمره
كامله طواف وسعي تقدم لهم الخدمه مج
واصاله من الفندق طيب هل دوركم اليوم فقط
انكم تقولوا مدى المعتمد روحي يمين او
يتجه المكان الفلاني وعربات اما هناك
ادوار لا نعلم عنها لا تجاوزنا المرحله
هذه الحمد لله بكثير غير التنظيم التنظيم
شيء مهم اداره الحشود كذلك نشارك في
التنظيم من ناحيه في ناس يقول لك انا
بشارك تطوع في الحرم لتنظيم الحشود الحمد
لله الان في توزيع الوجبات في الخدمات
الصحيه في الخدمات التعليميه هذه كلها
تقدم تطوعا وقرب الى الله تعالى السؤال
الاخير مع كثافه العدديه الاعداد
المتعتمرين حتى الان يعني نتكلم اليوم عن
اكثر من 12 مليون مؤتمر وزائر هل هم
قادرين على انهم يتحملونها في في العمل
تحت هذه الكثافه نعم لانهم قبل الموسم
وعندنا تقريبا خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه شارك
اكثر من 3000 و196 متطوع خلال 24 ساعه
الماضيه شكرا لك يا استاذ عادل اذا كان
حديث عادل اكثر من 3000 و900 متطوع خلال
24 ساعه شاركوا مع في مساعده وايضا ار
مسانده المعتمرين وزوار داخل المسجد
الحرام وهذه بعض الفرق التطوعيه او ايضا
بعض الفرق التطوعيه الذين لديهم تخصص معين
وهو ايضا
اعانه المعتمرين على العربات المتحركه وهي
عربات مجانيه بامكان استعانه اي مؤتمر
وزائر دخل المسجد الحرام لهذه العربات
اضافه الى ايضا التي تقوم يتم تدريبهم
صحيح طبعا هؤلاء نعم نعم لديهم قدره عاليه
ولديهم تدريب ايضا قبل فتره الموسم تحديدا
موسم رمضان باكثر من شهرين يقومون
بتدريبهم ايضا يقومون بارشادهم او توجيههم
لما كان الصحيح وايضا بحسب قدراتهم وكذلك
مؤهلاتهم التي يتمكنون من بعضهم يتحدثون
عده لغات ليس فقط اللغه العربيه فيكون
هناك عدد من المتطوعين الذين يقومون
بارشاد المعتمر والزوار باللغات التي
يمتلكونها من الحرم المكي مراسل العربيه
هاني صفيان شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه ولضيفك طبعا ومشاهدينا لمتابعه
ملفات العربيه المزيد ايضا من الاخبار
والتحليلات تابعوا موقعنا العربيه وايضا
رجاء مسح الكود الظاهر على الشاشه الخامسه
انتهت نلتقي غدا بمشيئه الله شكرا
للمتابعه مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]